le procès de l'assassinât du policier
xavier juge les sur les champs elysées
s'ouvre aujourd'hui le 20 avril 2010 est
en fin de journée karim cherfi mitraille
un fourgon de police et hugues xavier
juge les l'assaillant sera abattu dans
la foulée aujourd'hui quatre hommes
comparaissent devant la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris
ils sont accusés d'avoir aidé karim
chorfi à se procurer son arme et au
palais de justice de paris justement on
va tout de suite retrouvé notre reporter
estelle farges
[Musique]
bonjour estelle alors quatre hommes
devant la justice mais un seul comparaît
devant la cour d'assises spéciale avec
la qualification terroriste
oui oui nourdine à l'âme c'est son nom
il a 31 ans et il est accusé d'avoir
vendu la kalachnikov l'âme qui aurait
été utilisée par karim cherfi en avril à
2017 lors de son attaque sur les champs
elysées il est donc poursuivi pour
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
en vue de la préparation à d'un crime
alors pour l'accusation en nourdine alam
aurait vendu cette arme à karim cherfi
tout en sachant que ce dernier je cite
avait une volonté affichée est résolu
d'attenter à la vie d'un fonctionnaire
de police de son côté nourredinne alam a
qui ne présentent d'ailleurs aucun signe
de radicalisation religieuse selon l'
enquête ni avoir acheté à la kalachnikov
pour la revendre à karim cherfi aucune
trace de ces empreintes n'avait
d'ailleurs été à retrouver sur le fusil
d'assaut son avocate conteste donc la
qualification de terroriste estelle
qu'en est-il les trois autres accusés
[Musique]
eh bien ils sont a jugé pour détention
et ou cession adam
ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir joué un rôle
à des degrés différents dans la
fourniture de larmes à karim chorfi l
adn de deux d'entre eux avaient
d'ailleurs été retrouvé sur le fusil
d'assaut mais les la circonstance
aggravante de terrorisme n'a donc pas
été retenue contre eux pour rappel en
avril 2010 est xavier jugla alors qu'il
était en service se trouvait dans un car
de police en haut de l'avenue des champs
elysées un assaillant avait attiré
alarme automatique sur son véhicule à
turin si le policier pour l'avocat des
proches de la victime l'enjeu pénal du
procès et que l a cour qu'on reconnaisse
la complicité de nourdine alam procès
qui va se dérouler jusqu'au 18 juin
prochain merci beaucoup estelle pour
toutes ces précisions estelle farges en
direct devant le tribunal judiciaire de
paris